C'est une mesure qui préviendra la récidive
et qui, je l'espère,
sera suffisamment dissuasive
pour amener un peu d'apaisement
de pacification sur les réseaux sociaux.
Nos concitoyens rencontrent
chaque jour de l'insécurité sur Internet
et ça finit par saper leur confiance
dans le numérique et nous-mêmes,
comme responsables politiques,
comme famille politique,
on ne peut pas soutenir
sans garantir à nos concitoyens
et en particulier
à nos concitoyens les plus fragiles
et les plus vulnérables.
Je pense à l'exposition
de nos enfants, même très jeunes,
à des contenus pornographiques.
Je pense à l'exposition de nous tous et toutes,
aux campagnes de SMS frauduleux
qu'on a tous reçu de la part
prétendument de la Sécurité sociale,
des impôts, pour la vignette critères
et qui n'ont comme seul
objectif de nous piller
nos données personnelles ou bancaires.
Et pour cela, et bien,
le projet de loi prévoit une peine de bannissement
des réseaux sociaux pour les auteurs
de harcèlement.
C'est une mesure qui préviendra la récidive
et qui, je l'espère,
sera suffisamment dissuasive
pour amener un peu d'apaisement
de pacification sur les réseaux sociaux.